[Music]
[Applause]
hi everyone this is the third and final
part in a series of videos i filmed back
in 2018
where i drove from the uk to russia and
back again check out the previous videos
if you haven't done so already
the last one covered training aikido in
russia these can be found in the
description below
this section covers a return journey
traveling through eastern europe and
back home
i went via the russian enclave clinton
grad and also stopped by a dojo some of
you might recognize
i'll talk more about that later in the
video
anyway i hope you enjoy the journey back
and remember to leave any comments down
below
we're at the city center driving towards
estonia now
uh i think it should just be this
straight long road
d20 and it should just take us all the
way there
hey we're now reaching the international
[Music]
border
ultra
[Music]
[Applause]
so just got through passport control um
now in estonia my camera battery
actually died
as i just got to the border crossing i
got a bit of a grilling from the
estonian border officers
they said that i've gone through a red
light they were quite rude and not
particularly
welcoming however after about an hour
they'll let me go
it's still pretty warm it's about 31
degrees outside
oh my shoulder's killing me i don't know
what i did
i think it might have been from fire
spinning yesterday
but
it's taken i can barely lift it past
that point
ah anyway
hopefully i'll recover soon
yeah so uh we've just arrived in tallinn
and
it's now nearly half two
um i've had to stop along the way to
have a bit of a sleep
because i'm just so tired um
it's starting to catch up with me
anyway um yeah i'm gonna have a walk
around talon see what there is i haven't
decided yet whether i'm staying the
night or not um
i guess i'll see if i find somewhere to
stay if not i'll be just
headed straight over to uh latvia
um but ideally i'd like to find
somewhere to
stay tonight because then i'll have a
bit more time to
walk around the city tomorrow
it's 2am
i found a hotel i decided to stay
in tallinn
and it had a sauna jacuzzi and all the
rest of it
in the hotel so uh oh i had a salt sauna
as well
which i've never ever been to before um
anyway i went to that and
uh yeah ended up falling asleep
afterwards
um and i've only just woken up
um no i don't need dinner so i'm just
going for a bit of a walk to see what
see what there is uh i don't think
there's much
but uh hopefully i can find a kebab
place or something open
uh to grab something let's look around
[Music]
foreign
result managed to find a kebab and
i'm just going to eat this and then have
a bit of a walk and then head back
um i'm wandering around for ages trying
to find one and it just turns out
there's just one
kind of around the corner from where i
started so anyhow
all good um
i'm gonna find somewhere now just to
chill and eat these
just having a look around the castle and
the
city walls it's been pretty good so far
actually um
having to squeeze it all in before i set
off to
um
[Music]
so the all part of talon was
particularly nice to walk around and as
usual i spent a lot of time looking at
the weapons in the armouries
outside they also had an area to try out
archery so i thought i'd have a goal
myself
i'm no expert so if anyone does any
archery please let me know in the
comments because i'm curious to see if
there's anything i can improve on
it's slightly lower
prepared
yeah you have a nice group that means
you're doing it like consistently
and the same thing all over again which
is good sign actually
just take it like one centimeter lower
let me turn up
good thank you
[Music]
so
so i've left thailand now um i've just
stopped on the way
heading towards latvia
um i might stop again just before the
border to get some dinner so
see how i feel uh but yeah i should be
back in that while i should be in latvia
for this evening
[Music]
it's not raining since i've been in
finland
i think it's making up for it now
just by a place called bum bum um being
with to eat there or not
whether to find somewhere else or go for
a walk not sure
so i've just stopped for a bit of a walk
and quite nice little park
um i had a walk down to the beach as
well um
just by this fountain now and
[Music]
we're going to go and look this week
and then cross over to flavia
just reached up here
[Music]
so
[Applause]
it's 4 30 a.m um
would sleep at about half 10 yesterday
so early then i normally go to sleep and
i thought i'd get ahead of any traffic
not like there is much traffic
but i just woke up so
no point sleeping longer if i don't need
to um
and uh and driving to rodriguez now
i'm gonna be crossing over to lithuania
soon um
i've decided not to stop in riga i've
been there several times before
um and spent spending quite a bit of
time in that beer in general
um so uh yeah i'll just be heading
straight over to
lithuania he's never been there before
so um
[Music]
[Applause]
ah
so some of you might recognize where i
am here this was the aikido chole dojo
run by rocus leo
i stopped by to meet up with rocus and i
attended one of his last classes
he was teaching ukemi which is something
rocus is really good at
he's great at teaching beginners i saw
some of the students have a go at high
falls for the first time and i was quite
surprised how well they did
i'll leave a couple of the clips playing
from the class which covered forwards
and backwards rules
[Applause]
change the side go back so one
so a few times i change the size and
eventually i
change the sides at the back
i change the sides go forward
so changing sides without stopping
forward
since then rocus has actually stopped
aikido and the dojo is closed
however he does have an online ukemi
course and also runs the martial arts
journey
youtube channel i'll leave details in
the description below
so i'm still in the thorny i'm just
about to cross over to the cronian
spin it's like a slither of land
and that separates the sea from this um
uh lagoon um so it's still in lithuania
um but i'm going there before um
crossing over to uh back into russia
that was a quick ferry ride just took a
couple of minutes
just waiting to come off the boat now
stop here
[Music]
yeah so i've come off road um i'm not
sure if i'm supposed to be
here or not because there's no barriers
or anything
um or signs that doesn't seem to be
anyone else here
um it's quite quite empty um
there's a few you can see a few dirt
tracks
around but
i'm not seeing anyone oh
crap it's biting me
yeah this seems like a good spot to get
the drone out so um
i'll do that see if i can get both both
sides
[Music]
it's a bit worried there for a minute
and nearly got stuck in the sand
um i don't know how the drone footage is
going to look because uh
my phone packed in part way through
but we'll see
[Applause]
so i just stopped to have a look at this
view
in one of these towns this little uh
port
and um
start to hear the this uh buzzing and i
thought i was hearing things
from the the drone same same sort of
sound as the drone
uh but just faint and i thought it's
just me just going crazy
anyway there's all these little tiny
little um like midges or flies
in the car so i'm just trying to wear
the car now to get rid of them
i thought i was getting bitten
everywhere
there's loads of them so we're not
actually that
far away from the russian border now
um probably about half an hour half an
hour's drive
um but i'm not going to cross over to
russia today
i'll be staying the night here i'll find
somewhere today
do this in the back of the car again
[Music]
so i've mentioned russia before because
we're going to be heading back there
i'm going to be going to kaliningrad
the russian enclave between
sandwich between poland and lithuania
um my visa runs out on the 5th of
august so i've only got a few days um i
want to spend longer in lithuania
um and the other border countries
actually but
um if i was wanting to go to cleaning
grad i've had to kind of rush here so
i'm only going to end up
having a couple of days here so yeah
unfortunately
that's all i've got
feels like i'm in southeast asia with
all these um
taxis
[Music]
so this part's the
lagoon
it's absolutely beautiful but i don't
know if you can see but there's all
these little fish jumping up
and you won't be able to smell it
absolutely stinks of
absolutely stinks of rotting fish i
don't know why
well i don't know why because there's
loads of rotten fish but i don't know
why there's loads of rotten fish
oh everywhere
i know they say that you can't swim in
this part of the um
uh or any part of the lagoon i don't
think
um i don't know if there's something
contaminating it or
[Applause]
yeah it's a shame
the other side's nice though
[Applause]
on the sea i think i'll go there now
get away from the smell of
this fishy smell
[Music]
i was going to walk longer along the
coastline um
[Music]
the smell of stench of the dead fish
is just unbelievable um
[Music]
that's just making me give now i can
still smell it
[Music]
death valley
i'm not sure if it's because it bothers
russia or
because of all the dead fish
and fish on in the valley so
who knows i'll have to google it later
i'm going to grasp
back in russia
[Music]
and i'm gonna head into planing right
now
and check out the city
[Music]
miles away from england
strategy
[Music]
um
so
[Music]
[Applause]
i'm about to cross over to germany um
i've been driving across
poland not all yesterday um
i haven't really had much chance to stop
here because i needed to make it to
germany to spend some time in berlin
i need to make it back for my ferry so i
don't have much time
um ended up spending a bit longer in
lithuania than expected
um so yeah so i'm gonna crack on um i
should be in
berlin hopefully in a couple of hours
and then that will give me a full couple
of days
[Music]
so yesterday i found this slide in the
shopping mall
um i've been just thinking about it uh
i'm gonna try and go down it today and i
think it's just meant for kids but
it looks good
[Music]
after a productive morning i spent the
rest of the day exploring other parts of
berlin
up until the evening
[Music]
all right now's the long drive um i've
got
about 800 miles to do oh no 900 miles i
think
um and i've got uh
nearly 12 hours and saluting
i'm driving from berlin
back to dunkirk
and my ferry's back at 3am i think so
they got going
[Music]
[Applause]
hey guys uh back home now finally made
it back
um i've done uh 4461 miles
so just nearly about 7 000 kilometers
in total um from
saint petersburg it's just over 200
two and a half thousand uh miles
so the majority of the mileage i did was
on the way back
obviously because i'm not taking any
ferries uh i'm absolutely knackered now
so
i'm going to get some sleep get a bit of
rest um
and yeah i hope you enjoyed everything
and
i'll probably make some summary video
but now i'm too tired so
catch you later hi everyone
it's now summer of 2020 two years after
filming
this trip um it's taken a lot of editing
but i finally got
there i hope you all enjoyed it it'd be
good to hear your thoughts in the
comments below
also please remember to like share and
subscribe as this helps the channel grow
it's been a crazy year so far i hope
you're all keeping well
i've got some more content planned so
keep an eye out for future videos
and until then take care and i'll see
you soon
you